so
today the latest weapons coupled with
the fighting skill of the american
soldier stand ready on the alert all
over the world to defend this country
view the american people against
aggression
this is the big picture an official
television report to the nation from the
united states army
now to show you part of the big picture
here is sergeant stuart queen
the big picture you are about to see
might well have been titled disaster usa
for it pictures a recent great
catastrophe in our nation
something that might overwhelm any part
of the country and countless americans
at any time
it shows to the army corps of engineers
at work
they carry on their capable shoulders a
double duty
in war
the army engineers have the combat
function of building bridges and roads
so that the army can march on to victory
in peace
they are responsible for the civil works
of national stature
at harbors and along rivers whose waters
they control in mighty dams
this is today's big picture
if you have traveled among the original
13 states you know that many of the more
northern ones early developed industries
mills and factories driven by water
power gift of the swift ever flowing
rivers of the region
around the factories along the streams
grew up villages then towns then cities
for when industry no longer used water
for mechanical power it needed enormous
quantities of it for processing cooling
washing hydrating
now it was mid-summer 1955 hurricane
connie heading north had gentled down to
a hard rain and the thirsty ground
soaked it up such was the face of things
on the 17th of august 55.
to be sure hurricane diane had followed
connie's track northward and all america
side with relief when diane blew itself
out off the north carolina coast
but unobserved a thick canopy of water
soaked clouds continued on
and during the brief hours of august
18th and 19th dumped 10 to 20 inches of
tropical downpour on the lower
watersheds of eastern pennsylvania new
jersey southern new york connecticut
massachusetts and rhode island
the saturated soil could absorb none of
the deluge
dry ravines became roaring creeks creeks
became rivers rivers were swollen to
mighty torrents racing for the sea
carrying with them the debris of life
and living overwhelming and bursting
apart the work of generations of men
it was a flash flood of tremendous
proportions unprecedented in its
terrifying fury and violence in terms of
property damage the most costly flood in
american history millions of tons of
raging water smashing at factories shops
and homes
streets became river beds
while citizens that day were struggling
to save their possessions and themselves
the armed services were sending rescue
teams and supplies and the army's corps
of engineers responsible by
congressional statute for flood fighting
rushed engineer specialists and heavy
construction equipment to the flood
zone later that day the waters were
subsiding those who had escaped went
back to the work of rescue
the helpless the stranded were brought
to safety
the very old
and the very young
another few hours and the flash flood
was over the rivers were returning to
normal flow
now the devastation could be measured
more than 300 towns eroded smashed
gutted towns in which the army engineers
were already at work
thousands of buildings destroyed or
damaged
real loss
thousands of people homeless more than
one hundred thousand with their jobs
swept away
real cost almost 200 lives
hundreds of bridges destroyed or badly
damaged
even the dead were not spared
you will remember broadhead creek near
stroudsburg in pennsylvania
on this stark and empty plane stood the
14 rustic cabins of camp davis where 37
persons were swept to death in the
watery avalanche many of them women most
of them children
the state national guard and army units
promptly mobilized to guard direct and
comfort
channel clearance one of the first
objectives of the corps of engineers if
another downpour came the streams would
not be blocked and damned with debris
at bridge crossings the rubble of the
old made way for the launching of the
new
engineer units state employees and
civilian crews hired by the army's corps
of engineers erected more than 100
bailey bridges to connect up highways
and streets and thus end the isolation
of scores of cities and towns
the bailey bridge is like a king-sized
director set a well-trained crew can
assemble and launch one across a
100-foot stream in two and one-quarter
hours and it will carry from 28 tons to
60 tons depending upon its type
thousands of them were erected in
wartime by crack combat engineer teams
to span the rhine the voltorno the
rapido and the steep gullies of korea
as fast as a bailey was completed supply
and work vehicles of reconstruction
moved across
throughout the emergency signal core
mobile units maintained communications
transmitting reports and orders for food
equipment and medicines
and the army medical service was on
constant call
pure drinking water must be promptly
provided and that was an army engineer's
job undertaken by its specialists
tank trucks carried the water to the
waiting people
and mama's little helpers were ready and
willing
through the red cross came not only food
clothing and money but also the
medicines and serums which made possible
a winning fight against pestilence
military and civilian doctors inoculated
old and young against tetanus and
typhoid
everybody is happy and safe
the salvation army's mobile canteens
took care of all
kitchens were set up by the army's
national guard to feed those unable to
provide for themselves
everybody helped
those who had shared with those who had
not supplies poured in from the nation
nobody was forgotten
to children everywhere it was a picnic
it was no picnic to the parents of this
homeless family
but there were no tears
they went smiling through
railroads follow and cross the rivers
and therefore transportation was one of
the major victims of the disaster
the army's transportation corps
immediately took from their cocoons its
crack diesel engines stockpiled at fort
eustis for wars emergency for this was
war against a devastation as great as
any bombing attack
the crippled railroads rented the
engines for the emergency to return them
to their cocoons without expense to the
government
president eisenhower made a personal
survey of the devastated region
he saw for himself the extent of the
loss and suffering
shocked the president declared the
entire flood zone a disaster area he
called upon the federal civil defense
administration through its administrator
val peterson to bring relief to the
people of the stricken region
administrator peterson not only set his
own national organization to work he
also delegated to the army's corps of
engineers the duty of carrying out the
reconstruction phase of the president's
disaster order and operation noah was
born the army corps of engineers has a
unique organization in being which
covers the entire united states in 10
separate division areas each in charge
of a division engineer and each divided
into districts where required an
emergency in any part of the country
along any river system at an important
harbor or huge metropolitan target thus
could be met and promptly handled by
this engineer organization under the
direction of the chief of engineers in
washington
simultaneously the chief may alert the
entire nationwide organization and
dispatch reinforcements to the disaster
area
when the northeastern states were
declared a disaster area the north
atlantic and new england divisions
quickly organized for emergency
construction operations to affect speedy
recovery from the havoc wrought by the
disaster
the chief of engineers lieutenant
general samuel d sturgis jr at
washington telephoned his commands to
the north atlantic division chief of new
york and the new england division chief
at boston
to the disaster area he dispatched 49
officers by plane from fort belvoir the
engineer school and training center
and to help handle the added duty of
disaster relief within 24 hours 100 of
the core civilian engineers were flown
in from division and district
headquarters in the middle west and the
far west
about 50 field offices were immediately
set up in the disaster area and
additional reinforcements sent as needed
throughout the disaster area local
contractors had been given immediate
assignments
more than 500 contracts were spot
negotiated involving total cost of
several million dollars
engineers checked the work as it
proceeded
and engineer experts in soil mechanics
made field tests for pervious and
impervious material to be used in dikes
levees and fills
heavy equipment played a dominant part
in the miracle of rehabilitation it was
essential in the rapid moving of
mountains of earth and rock blocking the
avenues of recovery
more than one thousand two hundred
pieces of heavy equipment were being
employed simultaneously in the flood
area under contract
each type of equipment had its special
use and all types were employed in this
vast labor of repair and restoration
emergency repair of public utilities was
a desperate need
the army engineers were charged with the
immediate restoration of sewers and
water mains
at the forks of the lehigh and the
delaware where the flood crested shortly
after midnight august 19th
debris piled against the northampton
bridge damning the deluge momentarily
then the million-ton force of the flood
burst through
that was the story for scores of bridges
the clock was stopped later in the
morning of august 19th by the watery
fingers of connecticut's nagatok river
all connecticut was in the major
disaster area
down the nagatak came the towering wall
of water which contributed so greatly to
the state's toll of death and damage
the raging river picked up rocks and
rubble and flung them everywhere
a measure of the flood's power
heavy railroad rails bent and twisted by
the force of waterborne debris thrust
against them with a giant strength
and boxcars lifted up and smashed
against nearby buildings
winston stood in the flood channel of
the raging mad river it was rivaled only
by putnam as a place of destruction and
suffering
a large segment of the town was swept
away
at putnam alone two thousand were
homeless
in this factory magnesium was processed
flood
fire and explosions contributed to total
destruction
here the quinnipog river carved a new
channel through a railway cut
the engineers put the river back in its
bed
also in the quinnipog river valley at
the old massachusetts town of
southbridge destruction temporarily
drowned out the entire economy
but no flood could dampen the tough
yankee spirit of self-help
their homes might be gone but their
courage was still there
america pays homage to their nobility of
spirit
for those who still had houses house
cleaning after the torrent had wiped its
muddy feet on the rug
volunteer civil defense workers
continued to battle for their
townspeople
promptly leaders of cities and states
had initiated practical plans for aiding
families suddenly made homeless and
jobless
bailey bridges continued to arrive as
soon as the flood emergency became
apparent the army engineers had started
moving 13 carloads of baileys from their
huge stockpile in marion ohio to
railroad yards giving access to the
flood area
trucks were waiting to haul the bridges
to the road ends
food contamination and its threat of
diseased germs and insect carriers was a
menace handled by civil defense workers
the necessary cleaning out of flooded
stores and shops added to the task of
sanitation
sprinkler tank trucks were sent through
many towns by the engineers to spray
disinfectant on the piles of refuse
but here teenagers volunteered to spray
contaminated material with a ddt
solution
no flags are waving but this is the
american spirit in action
most floods are followed by an epidemic
of disease but the alert people of the
area denied diane that second victory
restoration of the normal flow of
community life went on rapidly the flood
had coursed through this street and
store leaving eight feet of rock and
rubble
within a few days
street and store were returning to life
and living
this avenue of wreck and rack
was in a short time back in business
and here where cranes rattled and swung
a traffic director soon was required
as you look over the scenes of vast
desolation you ask yourself
is this a first time for these cities
and peoples
this tragic story of flood and
devastation and death
has it ever happened before
yes
in 1938 this was the nagatak and the
lehigh and the quinnipog and the
connecticut
man's memory is so short
loss and devastation and death
this was hartford connecticut in 1938
this was the connecticut river in
hartford
this too was hartford in 1938
and this was the 1938 fashion in
hartford
look closely at hartford streets in 1938
compare them to hartford streets in 1955
yes
1955 when diane had come and gone
leaving hartford dry serene undamaged
what magic brought this about
no magic at all just plain common sense
flood control construction
since 1938 congress has authorized a 300
million dollar flood control program for
new england
this flood wall built by the corps of
engineers at a cost of 11 million
dollars was a part of that program
in 1955 it saved hartford twice its cost
in property damage
under the same authorization this flood
control dam was built on the westfield
river a tributary of the connecticut
during diane it largely controlled the
west field and diminished flood stages
along the entire connecticut
as part of the same program this dam was
constructed above willimantic in the
great diane storm it reduced flood
stages there and downstream on the
shuttucket and thames rivers
these dams stand dry until a record
downpour threatens then the control
gates are closed and the reservoirs fill
with billions of gallons which otherwise
would pour into the swollen streams and
build them to raging floods with the
emergency passed the gates are open and
the impounded waters drain away
but man's memory is short and 5 6 of the
authorized 300 million dollar program
has not taken form in flood control
works the unbuilt dams levees and flood
walls would have reduced the damage
might have saved lives even in such a
flood as diane the plans for watershed
development to contain flood waters and
protect the cities and peoples from
destruction and death remain largely
uncompleted
and the flood control plans in many
other areas of our nation are also
largely uncompleted the nation's rivers
can be controlled
remember the 1927 flood on the
mississippi
remember the 37 flood on the ohio
remember the 51 and 52 floods on the
missouri
in the wake of the rampages of these
wild rivers the engineers great earth
dams on the missouri like fort peck and
garrison
and fort randall rise to harness the big
money and tame its periodic overflows
the levee system on the mississippi and
the dams on its tributaries have
contained the father of waters
these engineering works are man's answer
to nature's wrath
and our army's engineers are a part of
the great team dedicated to the unending
fight for flood control and the
development of our river basins for
america's security and prosperity
but without this constructive work we
must continue to face tragedy
destruction and heartbreak
yet with the passage of time the memory
of raging waters fades and is forgotten
must man's memory continue to be so
short
so as you have seen
the army corps of engineers have done
much for our country
and will do so much more if given the
go-ahead signal
it does seem strange that we americans
who enjoy so many blessings
could enjoy so many more if only we took
thought of past disasters and planned
ahead to control them in the future
truly our memory need not be so short
this is sergeant stuart queen
inviting you to be with us again next
week for another look at the big picture
the big picture is a weekly television
report to the nation on the activities
of the army at home and overseas
produced by the signal corps pictorial
center
presented by the united states army in
cooperation with this station
you too can be an important part of the
big picture
you can proudly serve with the best
equipped the best trained the best
fighting team in the world today the
united states army